let's say we've got two countries
country a and country b
and at the start of our little
hypothetical thought experiment they
have a very stable exchange rate maybe
it's one for one every a
if you were to go into the into foreign
currency markets you could get a b for
it so there's kind of this
stable supply and demand between these
two currencies now let's say for
whatever reason folks in a start to
believe that b country b is the hot
place to invest they want to buy country
b's real estate they want to invest in
country b's stock market and so if they
want to buy stuff in b they essentially
have to hold more of b's currency and so
more and more people
more and more people in a want to
exchange their a's for country b's
currency so you have this huge supply of
a's coming onto the foreign exchange
markets but you still have the same
amount of b's that want to go that want
to go the other way maybe and you know
these are maybe there to either invest
in country a or maybe buy some of
country's a's exports or whatever it
might be but if we just let this happen
on its own where all of a sudden there's
a much larger demand for converting a's
into b then converting b's into a
you'll have a situation where the b's
will just get more expensive there's
more demand for b's than they are for
a's they'll get more expensive in terms
of a's so if you look at it from country
a's point of view you're now having to
pay more more a's
per b and a completely equivalent
statement from country b's perspective
you would now have to pay fewer
fewer
bees
fewer bees per a
now let's say for whatever reason you
are the central bank you are the central
bank right over here of
country b
and you don't like your currency
becoming stronger maybe you just don't
like the volatility in the exchange
markets you don't like the
the idea that the exchange rates go up
and down so dramatically maybe you just
don't want your exports to get expensive
or that imports from another country to
get cheap for whatever reason you do not
like this movement happening and so
you're what you're going to do is
because you have the right to do it you
you are the central bank of your country
you can print more of your currency
right here the currency b's
so you're going to print more of these
so you're
you could print more of them just like
that and then you can use that extra b
that you just printed to buy more a's
and so now you've kind of re-normalized
the supply and the demand for bees but
what's going to be the end product of
that well you did successfully keep your
currency from appreciating relative to
the a's which based on how this was all
set up that was your goal but the other
thing that you ended up with is since
you printed b's and you're able to buy
a's in the open market you now on your
balance sheet or maybe in your vaults
you have a bunch of a's and so when
people talk about foreign currency
reserves let me write it down foreign
currency reserves and pretty much every
bank every central bank has foreign
currency reserves this is what they are
talking about that central bank printed
their own currency and went out into
currency foreign exchange markets and
bought other countries currencies and
there's multiple reasons for them doing
it this might be one of them or it might
be to protect them in the case that this
whole dynamic reverses in the other
direction especially if it reverses in a
very dramatic way